l'évacuation de la ville de Carson et
achevée selon les autorités prorus une
évacuation alors qu'une bataille
s'annonce avec l'armée de Kiev l'Ukraine
qui mène une offensive dans la région
après avoir infligé de sérieux revers
aux forces russes sur d'autres fronts
retrouve Gulliver crack notre
correspondant dans la région de dessin
quelle est la situation sur le terrain
actuellement
alors il n'y a pas de percée majeures
dans la région de Herson les Ukrainiens
admettent que leur progrès est
sévèrement ralenti par les conditions
météorologiques essentiellement la boue
mais il y a eu cette évacuation non
seulement des civils mais aussi du
gouvernement d'occupation dirigée par le
collaborateur Volodia saldo qui aurait
apparemment quitté la ville d'aersonne
pour la rive droite cela s'accompagne en
revanche par des renforts en termes de
soldats déployés par les Russes en tout
cas c'est ce que disent les
renseignements Ukrainiens les militaires
Ukrainiens aujourd'hui on parlait de
1000 soldats russes supplémentaires
déployés dans la ville des Herson mais
ce qu'il ne faut pas oublier c'est qu'il
y a une campagne aussi de désinformation
délibérées et assumées par Kiev qui
envoie parfois des messages un peu
contradictoires concernant ce qui se
passe à Herson avant-hier le ministre de
la Défense au lycée restnico va dit que
c'est fait tout à fait exprès on ne veut
pas qu'il sache qu'on sait ce qu'ils
font c'était ces mots donc les deux
côtés essaient de faire en sorte de
laisser passer le moins d'informations
possibles et parfois même de faire
passer des informations qui peuvent
s'avérer par l'avenir fosse pour juste
induire l'ennemi en erreur vous vous
trouvez sur le port de la mer Noire les
exportations de céréales depuis 3
semaines sont plus difficiles
oui l'Ukraine accuse la Russie de
ralentir les inspections selon l'accord
conclut le 22 juillet avec la médiation
de la Turquie et les Nations Unies les
Russes ont le droit d'inspecter les
navires qui se dirigent vers les ports
Ukrainiens de la mer Noire
essentiellement pour vérifier qu'il n'y
a pas d'armes selon le ministère
ukrainien de l'infrastructure jusqu'il y
a environ trois semaines ces inspections
prenaient environ une heure par
inspection et tout se passait
relativement bien maintenant la Russie
met à disposition beaucoup moins de
personnels pour les inspections chaque
inspection prend beaucoup de temps avec
pour beaucoup plus de temps qu'avant je
veux dire avec pour résultat qu'il y a
plus de 160 navires en ce moment bloqué
dans le Bosphore qui doivent venir sur
les ports Ukrainiens pour exporter des
grains résultat à nouveau les
agriculteurs
Ukrainiens ne peuvent pas réaliser leurs
production je parlais ce matin avec un
agriculteur dans le centre du pays qui
m'a dit que depuis deux semaines les
ports de la région de dessin pour lui en
tout cas sont fermés il ne peut plus
envoyer sa production vers ses ports
donc il a encore des hangars qui sont
pas vidés il n'y a pas de place pour
faire sa récolte de maïs le maïs reste
dans les champs avant tant qu'il n'aura
pas résolu ce problème et bien sûr cela
provoque des pénuries de grands sur les
marchés d'exportation de l'Ukraine et
une nouvelle flambée des prix